[Musique]
deux avions survolent à basse altitude
la région parisienne puis soudain j'ai
entendu comme une déflation ça a fait un
peu peur l'amérique rassembler autour de
ses symboles son hymne et ce drapeau
déchiré retrouver au world trade center
il y a vingt ans le gros porteur grille
n'est pas un avion civil mais militaire
escorté par un rafale à son bord le
premier ministre jean castex et la
ministre des armées florence parly comme
l'expliquent matignon jean castex a
participé à un exercice de
ravitaillement en vol de deux rafale à
bord d'un a330 mrtt qu'il a ensuite
ramené à villacoublay et pour faire de
nos espoirs la réalité de nos vies
j'ai décidé d'être candidate à la
présidence de la république enfin elle
joue beaucoup anne hidalgo sur une femme
à l'elysée justement oui mais elle joue
beaucoup tout comme elle a joué avec les
parisiens quant à leur a écrit noir sur
blanc jeunes seraient en aucun cas pour
candidate à la présidence de la
république elle joue avec l'équité nous
parlions des retraites il ya quelques
instants vous avez par exemple que les
35 heures s'applique dans notre pays
depuis quelques années et bien pas la
mairie de paris parce que à la mairie de
paris madame hidalgo a fait une
proposition pour qu'on travaille moins
de 35 heures manuel macron à rogner les
libertés des français au fur et à mesure
de son mandat et il est temps de
réoxygéner notre pays parce que la
liberté c'est notre valeur fondamentale
des centaines d'afghanes entièrement
voilées visage compris tout en noir elle
se sont réunis dans l'amphithéâtre de
l'université de kaboul pour exprimer
leur soutien au régime des talibans
utilisation du mot et libertés par
marine le pen c'est une totale imposture
une totale imposture c'est une une femme
qui soutient des régimes des
gouvernements qui le portent atteinte
aux libertés souvenez vous elle a
soutenu viktor orban pour n'être pas
candidat pour l'instant je ne suis pas
vous y ferez pas dire vous ne pouvez pas
dire ce soir je ne serai pas candidat
non je ne le dirai pas ce soir je dis
que je pense je déciderai je le dis ça
veut dire vous réfléchissez encore
exactement fera baisser les femmes avoir
un discours misogyne c'est pas possible
pour moi d'ailleurs d'ailleurs il ya un
paradoxe zemmour un paradoxe et moore il
dit qu'il veut lutter contre l'islamisme
c'est ce qu'on peut être pu lutter
contre l'islamisme s'en défendre
l'égalité femmes-hommes monsieur zemmour
aujourd'hui il a des tribunes
médiatiques et très peu de
contradicteurs et qui serait donc
peut-être le temps de lui apporter la
contradiction j'ai vu que jean luc
mélenchon il y avait proposé de le faire
très franchement moi j'appelle de mes
voeux à ce qu'un débat de ce type puisse
exister je pense que la france que
j'aime que j'ai aimée est en train de
disparaître et si vous voulez je n'ai
pas du tout envie de ça j'ai pas du tout
envie de l'avenir qu'on nous promet que
la démographie nous promettent que les
bons esprits nous promettent que les
belles âmes promettent que la lâcheté
des politiques nous promet je n'ai pas
envie d où français arrive t'as pas le
bon prénom et si si je réussis je
prendrai une loi pourtant empêché
d'avoir ton prénom pour moi c'est
absolument le contraire
de du devoir qui est le nôtre comme
français cent vingt mille personnes à
nouveau descendus hier dans les rues de
nombreuses villes de france elles
étaient 140 milles samedi dernier
mobilisation en baisse donc à quelques
jours pourtant de l'entrée en vigueur de
l'obligation vaccinale pour les
professionnels de santé puisque c'est
mercredi il est des batailles qu'on n'a
pas le droit de perdre
amy nationaux l'élection présidentielle
de 2022 est de celles là et parce que
nous n'avons pas le droit de la perdre
nous allons la gagner marine le pen ne
gagnera jamais fort par ailleurs tous
les genres fractional le savent et parce
que tout simplement
vous avez vu son débat il ya quatre ans
face à emmanuel macron non je ne trouve
pas qu'elle ait progressé eric zemmour
fait partie de ceux qui croient en la
france nous avons des divergences c'est
sûr je pense qu'on gagne dans l'union et
pas dans la division donc je ne le
traiterait jamais comme un adversaire et
je pense qu'il devrait réserver ces
attaques à emmanuel macron